welcome to academy dialogues it starts
with us
my name is sean finney and we're about
to get into the second in our continuing
series of conversations about race
ethnicity identity history and the
opportunity in the art of filmmaking
our theme today is native sun native sun
was founded by veteran magazine editor
cultural change maker and lgbtq activist
emil wilbecken
with the intention to create a safe
space for black gay men to celebrate our
achievements
build community and inspire one another
we are so grateful to have a meal
moderating today's conversation which
will focus on growing the voice
and the visibility of black gay men in
hollywood and the film industry
emil has held editor-in-chief positions
at vibe and giant magazine
ben both managing editor and
editor-at-large at essence
style guru at complex and chief content
officer for the annual afropunk festival
speaking with the mill our writer
director producer lee daniels
and writer terrell alva mccraney who
have agreed to share
their stories lee directed the film
precious
based on the novel push by sapphire
precious received
six oscar nominations including best
picture and took home
two oscars that night for best
supporting actress and made history with
the best adapted screenplay win
making jeffrey fletcher the first ever
african-american man to win an oscar for
writing
he also produced monsters ball for which
halle berry became the first
and so far only black woman to win a
best actress oscar
he also created the tv series empire and
star
both of which he produces and directs
terrell alva mccraney is an academy
award winner for best adapted screenplay
for the film
moonlight for which he co-wrote based on
his play
and the moonlight black boys look blue
he also wrote high flying bird directed
by steven soderbergh which was released
on netflix last year thank you all for
participating in academy dialogues and
for sharing your stories
we look forward to your conversation
well thank you gentlemen for being here
with us today
um our topic is the growing voice and
visibility
of black gay men in hollywood and in
the film industry um you know as black
gay men
we live in triple consciousness we're
black
we're gay and we're men and particularly
as we move
through the world right now
all of those things come into play at
every intersection
uh native sun is framed after
james baldwin's notes of a native son
and it's very
interesting that within notes of a
native son
he criticizes portrayals of black people
in hollywood and notably
talks a lot about dorothy dandridge and
carmen jones
why is it important that we have this
conversation
about black amen and our identity and
our sexuality
and our masculinity and amplify
uh our voice invisibility in hollywood
lee let's start with you
first of all what was the read on
dorothy dandridge may i ask
what was he saying about dorothy
dandridge it was more of how black
people were depicted
in carmen jones and so you know are we
showing full pictures
are we sexualized how are we showing
black people
um and i think that's something that we
all grapple with today
mm-hmm now i i was so concerned i was so
uh into the carmen jones of it all but i
forgot
i forgot the question one more time sum
it up real quick
yes so why is it important for us
to have these conversations as black gay
men
about our masculinity our identity and
our sexuality
and amplify these our voice invisibility
in hollywood especially right now
because this is where it starts right
here this is all where it starts right
here
um there is a conception
or a misconception of what the
african-american
uh gay male is
and um not every body looks like
uh or acts like um
what they perceive us to be i mean it's
a hard question right it's like really
hard question i want to make sure i'm
clear you know
well also also i think part of you know
what i think
some of the question is and lee you know
i'd love to hear what
what you have to say about it is you
know
how do we get to a place where we're
talking to each other
right like so many of the questions and
so many of what we want to talk about is
always
asking hollywood to give us something
or to make us space for us and it's like
and
and it gets harder because we we're
constantly
begging for space to be human like give
us room so we can be all the
many versions of ourselves something
that you alluded to
uh many times when we've talked is that
look there's as many versions of being
black and gay as there are
black and gay people right there are
many versions of it and
you if you just show one version then
you are limiting that
that uh people's history um and
and humanity to that just narrow scope
um
and we shouldn't have to ask to get a
little bit more space to show
all the variations um we shouldn't have
to keep begging for that
um and so it's a hard question to ask
because it's like well you know we've
been asking for almost
uh for almost 400 years right um
and you know from theater to music
to film to you know to the internet
we keep getting these sort of narrow
channels to be
fully human and i think that's why it's
a hard question to answer
um and and lee you've been doing it
way longer than i have thank you for
that
thank you for that tyrell because it
threw me for a little bit a little
loop yeah i mean it's it's like peeling
an onion
it's like peeling an onion it's so
layered and so
complicated that question emil
um
it is very very difficult doing what we
do
it is very very uh difficult uh
having to face uh your own people
forget about white people
forget about hollywood but your own
people
as a black gay man
as a masculine walking black gay man
because people are thrown by it they
don't really see
or they don't want to see uh
it confuses people it throws people off
and uh
so one one of the things that i want to
ask both of you
is that you know within native sun we
talk about this
in hollywood we talk about it in
corporate america and in media
there's a sense of isolation we still
live in this
we're the only one in the room it could
be
at yale it could be at you know at fox
or at you know amazon wherever you're
working
netflix we're the only ones and so
how do you navigate being the only one
and telling your story without fear of
being
quieted i think uh
for me i can't speak for terrell but for
me
uh i grew up in the streets
you know i grew up with a family of drug
dealers
i grew up you know
unafraid and i took
that unafraidness
into my concept of
of how to break into hollywood you know
no one was going to tell me
that i was nothing or that i wasn't
going to have anybody tell me
that i wasn't worthy of it and look it
starts with talent first you have to
have talent there are
there are i think you you can't just
fake it you have to have something that
god has given you
that you know that you can count on at
the end of the day
and once you have that i'm just speaking
for me you know
once you have what you think uh is
this talent um
that is your backbone for um
getting in the room as malcolm x says by
any
by any means necessary so i
didn't it didn't by any means necessary
is how i got into the rooms by any means
necessary you know i was going to do
what i had to do to get into the room
so that i was going to do what i had to
do to make sure that monster's ball got
into existence
that halle berry won the academy award
by any
means necessary and
uh so now it doesn't it doesn't really
i'm not it's not about by any means
necessary it's by uh
but i will resort to that if i have to
right
but do you find now that you're in the
room
that you're still the only black gay man
in the room
who is presenting these stories that are
other that are
you know the story the narratives we
never hear well i surround myself now
with as many black gay men as i can so
i'm not the only one in the room
when i'm creating these stories but when
i'm pitching these stories oftentimes
that is the case
and um it is uh
it's really interesting you know this
this generation today we're in a
different space where that
um people just are accepting uh anything
for as talent because it's other
as opposed to looking at the talent now
now the message is woke as opposed to
the talent
you know is it woke okay let's do it
let's do it um so a lot of people are
getting passes on mediocrity
um gay people and black people
but uh no you have to be born with the
talent you have to be
as it's a gift from god that that drives
you
forward into the room and propels you
into into uh
into a space where that uh and i can
only again speak for me
where you do not take no for an answer
and this is going to happen
my way right so terrell what about you
um you know being the only one in the
room
how do you navigate that from a
creative space from an empowering space
um from a survival space um
i think well first of all i think you
know white people
have been allowed mediocrity for 400
years and i think
so i think i'm all right with you know
a little mediocrity here and there from
us um
we've had to be super and over talented
in every way shape or form
and so you know i think i don't i don't
mind
i don't mind so much i also am very much
you know like lee said i i make sure you
know when i do say
uh i'm blessed and lucky
and fortunate and had people like lee
and like many people
before me to make spaces for me and
inform the stories i want to tell
and in that um and in that way
um i'm able to say no you can't fill my
room
with you know as many white executives
as you want i actually would like for
you to
fill it with you know it's almost as if
and it was so funny because my best
friend and i were having this
conversation
i really wanted to do i wanted to work
with um some writers some black gay
writers
um who you know we respect we're around
the same age we respect each other's
work
um and and when i said hey we all want
to do a project together people looked
at me like i was crazy
um because you're just not allowed to
put that many
of the same thing in the room when it's
black right it's just you can't put that
you know put all of them in the same
room they're going to let them do
something that's crazy that's wild
right um and but as lee said you
sometimes just have to keep saying no
until the room
looks more and more like you right so
you keep saying
no to um all of the other
reasons why you should you know go with
this tried and true method that
um rather than the un um the the on
the unpaved ground right the ground
that's untrotted
um and so i i deal with in that way
it it and unlikely i'm not as brave all
the time
you know i do get scared um and i get
scared because i want to make sure i'm
protecting folk
um you know people are vicious people
people are vicious and mean
and i don't want to bring anybody up and
not be able to protect them
and so if you just look around you're
just bringing people to a place and they
have they're not ready and not looking
out for
all the things that this you know very
capitalist
very uh hungry industry can do
you sometimes watch a friend get really
hurt by
you know other stuff right
and i think you know anything um bell
hooks has a saying about anything that
estranges us or alienates us um
one from another is uh it serves the
interests
of racism and discrimination and i just
i i i get i i wanna i'm a protector in
that way
so i try my best to make sure hey if i'm
bringing you along i wanna make sure
that
you know we in this together and that i
can i have enough energy and strength
and focus
that i'm you know that i can make sure
that we're all doing our best work here
on on sort of um
just yeah
as free as free as we can be i was about
to say free
but you know in america there's so such
a
such a tax on that word now we don't
even know if we can use it anymore are
we
are we really free um but we're trying
to get there i'm trying to get free
tyrell that's why i love you man i mean
like the idea
this is and you it's a total
generational thing you know
like i would have never thought to think
of the mediocrity that white people have
put out this is the
i mean of course it's a no-brainer it is
a no-brainer
but we have been
trained brainwashed to believe that we
have to be the best that we
are in whatever it is if they are
good we have to be even better
so already that comment right there
shows the disconnect
from uh you know from my generation to
your generation and um thank you for
correcting me on that
you know it's good it's it's good it's
part of it's not it's an evolution it's
it's
i am learning so much from uh from
this change that's happening right now
you know because uh
i approached uh the rooms i approached
uh
getting projects done in such a uh
iconoclastic way it just wasn't
it was by any means necessary and so uh
and then when i was on you like i had to
make sure
that once it was uh done that it was
perfect you know
so uh i won't be so hard i guess on
some of the african-american some of the
black stuff that i've seen
you know i'm hard on it i'm hard on i'm
hard on stuff anyway
but i'm extra hard on what it is that we
have and i shouldn't be
this is a wake up thank you for that no
i think listen i
i believe we must make space so that we
can interrogate
we can critique we can you know but we
we need to do
that together and have those
conversations that's how we grow that's
how cultures grow
by nothing you know nothing uh
gets a pass you know we we you know
especially with us we don't
we can go into the barbershop and he
gonna have five or six
uh variations on why you know that film
didn't work
um or it did work i mean i've had people
sit me down and tell me
you ain't seen a play ever in their life
i was the first player they ever went to
on broadway and then tell me like
well you know in that third act if you
would have just did
x and you know and that
and that's okay i think there's there's
moments but i think in terms of or at
least the way the question was for
uh placed to me in terms of like
trying to live up to whatever they need
us to live up to
or trying to push something uphill it's
like yo
if they highlight if they green lighting
stuff that they
don't know is mediocre and there's a
brother getting or sister getting paid
for it
i'm not about to block anybody's money
like i'm just too rough out here
that does that mean i don't uh want to
help and encourage rigor
and exploration of their best art and
their best form of course but that's for
us
i want you to do your best not not
because i want you to prove anything to
them i want you to do your best because
it will help us
look at ourselves and see who we are
better yeah
it's it's interesting you you mentioned
uh terrell how
um how gracious lee was and how he
really
sat you down and talked to you um and so
it's funny lee to hear you
he doesn't sit anybody down to talk to
them
okay lee gonna tell you on the
lee was like come to set and while i'm
doing 70 different things i'm gonna drop
some gems on you
so now i don't know if there was a sit
down as opposed to you see that don't do
that [ __ ]
moving on like right i i get those calls
um all the time what what were some of
the things that
that lee dropped on you and wisdom that
he shared with you that
that helped you pave your way
i just remember there there was one
thing that lee said
um there were many things that lisa but
there was one thing that lee says that i
actually say
to my students and to myself
consistently like a little mantra
which is that they don't know us better
than we know us
don't ever let them make you pretend or
pay you enough money
to to get you to say that they actually
know more about us than they do
you don't have no just like i said about
the the nurse working five shifts
knows more about halle berry's struggle
in monsters ball
than any exact any executive does and
that she knows it she knows what that
struggle is she knows
what that and so don't you know
trust that you have to trust it you try
to trust that you and that you know
this life this world this
even if it's fantasy even if it's sci-fi
from this perspective you know it and
you
and you hold the key to it um and it
just it helps me because i
there have been many a moment where
someone has asked me to explain my
blackness or my queerness or my black
queerness
and i've just been like i'm good today
like i'm good on explaining it today
like you either get it or you don't like
it or don't you know don't
don't don't pay for it don't don't
greenlight it
but i'm not explaining it today um and i
think
you know um i
i definitely owe that to lee like i i
can't i hear him saying it in my mind
when when those moments happen
thanks daryl yeah it's interesting
thank you right we thank you lee
for sure it's interestingly that you
don't think that you
are um that you're not kind of moving
things forward in a radical way i think
that
every story that you've told and every
way that you
fundraised and and and cast
you've always pushed outside of the box
to create
opportunities for other black gay
storytellers to come up for someone like
terrell
to be able to you know win the oscar for
moonlight and
for you know jordanie cooper to have an
opportunity
to do storytelling um
[Music]
that well it comes second nature you
know because you know
the gift is not yours god didn't give
you the gift
the gift is that so your gift is to make
sure that it's passed on
and you know there was a time in
hollywood when i came to hollywood where
you had to be the only one that was very
competitive and
it has i mean i was the only black gay
person that was out at least that was
out
um as a filmmaker but
there was comp major competition and
you know that crabs in the barrel thing
um
amongst black people so um
and so you didn't really pass it on it
was all bs you really didn't pass it on
um but i knew instinctively as a gay man
you know that i had to pass it on
because otherwise i would be the only
one
and i needed that i needed that i knew
that there were people that were far
more talented than me
that were out there that i really wanted
far more talented than me you know that
i wanted to hear their invoices
and i wanted to see that direction and i
wanted to see their productions
and so um and so if i didn't pass it on
i was missing out on the opportunity
you know does that make any sense yeah
absolutely yeah
absolutely how do we so i don't really
look at it i don't i'm sorry i don't
really
look at it as uh you know for me
it was survival it was about uh it
is about um it's never been about the
money
ever been about the money it is about um
making sure that your work lives forever
and that i am affecting in particular
young black kids that are gay
in particular you know that what message
am i sending to them
that's uh that's what it's about
even if the even if the situations are
provocative or if it's a sexual
situation or if it's something that they
should
like what like what is it that will
um make these kids think that they also
wow this is a world that that i can see
that i know
that um that we don't see what is lee
bringing to us that we don't see and
terrell how do you
um and that's very scary that's scary
emil to do that
not to cut you off but that's really
scary that is a when you're in the
middle of that
i am afraid i'm not afraid of getting it
or or i'm
i'm not afraid of um i am not afraid of
of getting the money or convincing
somebody else to tell the story but once
you're in
the middle of telling the story i am
terrified
and are you are you terrified because
you want it to be um authentic
that you want it to be um healing
i mean what are what is all of the above
that i am am i
healing someone you are it's it's as
close to god as i get
you know when i'm in that space of
creating
so i want to make sure that it is
definitely affecting you
and i'm if i'm in the face of god i am i
am i am happy and i am afraid
and then that fear then drives the
creativity as well
yes sorry go back to tokyo
no no this is this is the conversation
so there's no
there's no you know start and stop um
terrell
you talked about bringing you know other
black talent along
uh how do you do that how do you do that
um through your you know production
deals how do you do that
as you're navigating your own path um
in hollywood um i mean you know there's
no formula
i think i just look around and you know
every project that i'm working on
if you know i try to make sure if black
is and
um that the people who are working on it
are as black as the story
are um you know i i mean
you know it's true i just you know when
i i try to and then sometimes
sometimes i don't you know all i don't
get it you know 100
sometimes i you know they're the
director might not be black or
um you know the the some of the cast
might not be black or some of the grip
or the dp
but i try i really do try and just go oh
yo
you know uh artists who's been working
in chicago and killing it for
20 years you've never had a role like
this here
please take it and you know and have to
spend the kind of
time and effort and you know making sure
people understand why that this is such
a pivotal point for this for this artist
um
but i just keep you know pulling where i
can and and
and you know and and i do that pretty
unapologetically
now like i said i'm not perfect and i
definitely tire out
so sometimes i fail sometimes i don't
you know get it to the
but i look to people like lee to like to
like ava who figure out ways to go oh no
you know every director on this episode
is going to be
a black woman you know or every every
uh per every dp or every camera person
is going to be x
you know we try i try to get that
organizational voice but as lee said
sometimes when i get mired down in the
writing of the thing
i just get so focused on making sure
that the word is right that i look up
and i go damn it i also need to pay
attention to these
seven other things um but you know if
you don't
for me it's also i need community
for me personally like i need to look i
need to be able to look around and go
ain't this bottom
to someone who understands that without
having to explain it so
i i just try to move with rather than
solo
um and no and you know there's tempting
moments all the time where people will
go oh
come on through this door and then you
try to come in and all your people come
with you and like oh
not all y'all just you right and you and
you kind of have to be like
oh well we can't i mean i need them in
order to
sit down right i need them in order to
stay sane i need them in order not to
throttle you
in five seconds because they're gonna
keep me you know easy and so
you know you kind of have to move as one
sometimes and
and i know um you know the
the saying is often like oh well i'll
get through the door and then i'll open
something for you
it's like well sometimes i just will
stay outside until we all can get in
um and i know people have been like well
that's why you aren't you know
you know a part of the academy that's
why you aren't this and that i'm like
that's cool
that's fine but i i'm more i'll wait i'd
rather wait i'd rather wait till we all
can
kind of walk on through you know
so you're not a part of the academy but
you
have won an oscar for
for your writing for moonlight um this
is a this is so upsetting to
uh to even we talked about this earlier
and um it is it traumatized me that
that that little rehearsal we had that
conversation that we had earlier when
i got that information spun me out of
control and um
and it's indicative of the space that we
are in
at the academy we're trying again i i
bring it up because that
that was a genuine conversation that
happened someone literally said to me
well
you know you need to fight you need to
fight for your your positioning and your
standing and i was like well i'm sure
there are other people who didn't
get you know i'm sure there's a you know
there's a list of folks who didn't sort
of walk through the threshold
and i'd rather fight you know for us
than just like my spot right um
and what would it call you know and
again it's that thing about time let me
just tell you
you will be into the academy this year
my god just
okay so that's a this this is a rap
conversation that's done speaking of let
me just i'm gonna talk about your work
for a second
wig out
i
you do feel alone you know emil i don't
know whether you saw that play did you
see the play
okay so i always feel that i am alone
i felt that way until i saw this cat's
work
you just feel like uh
you're the specificity of that black
gay man's mind is is so
specific it's just so the humor the
the the banter the pacing the
everything i sat there and watched that
play
uh i don't know where was it the public
where was it at i don't know where it
was at but it was
it was at the venue dude let me tell you
it was a it was i saw the birth of a
soul
and i knew that i i just you know i it
was it was a given and it
made me feel so good that you know i
wasn't alone i felt
i felt alone well george
george wolf's earlier works uh the
colored museum
uh you know he felt i felt like okay
he's out there
but you know but george was out there
you know and um
and then i saw this cat as like oh man
you know
you're not alone and it's a really great
feeling to not be alone
you know it's good and and i'm sure that
they're
jordan cooper is another
julian breece is another do you know
it's what we have gone through is what
we've experienced
as black gay men it's very specific to
feeling
uh and when you are able to
express that in any form it's pretty
breathtaking
it's pretty groundbreaking
it's what we bring to the table yep
yup so how do we
how do we bring more people to the table
i mean i understand what terrell's
saying about bringing people with him
but
what do you tell what's advice for young
people
who want to become filmmakers who want
to tell their stories
but don't know how to get there how do
we
what advice can we give them wow i mean
they
they are teaching me i mean they you
know the the
great news is that these young people
are not waiting around for
terrell to tell them to do nothing um
you know they
with you know uh you know barry talks
about this all the time with
the just their phones even the ones that
aren't the latest
iphone or i mean they can
film quality film and or dig
or digital film and stream it and get
and get
entertainment um i've seen seven seconds
of
drama that has like blown me away
um you know and i go on these you'll see
me sometimes i'll go on these little
gofundmes and they'll be like go fund me
i'm doing a 20-minute short and i'll be
like yo 20 minutes short is going to be
amazing
here the five dollars that i got for you
to keep investing and doing it and they
you know they've democratized um film in
a way that i know a lot of people are
scared
i know a lot of gatekeepers are scared
and i think rather than run away from
them
we have to embrace their voices we have
to embrace what they have to say and how
they want to say they're showing us new
ways
they're showing us new methods and you
know
i'm excited about it i don't know that i
have to tell them anything i think
i think the job is what donnie hathaway
said you know teach them well and let
them lead the way
i love that i just i just wonder with
that though
if we have an old guard hollywood how do
we get
those young avant-garde radical
filmmakers in front of these
other places to get money
to get opportunities to be able to be
seen
well again neil it's again you know it's
not your gift you know it's not your
gift it's your job
it's my duty to seek out these talents
there's only so many stories i have
there's only so many stories that i can
even write or i can be
you know i can direct there's only so
many but if you are seeking out
if you're seeking out then uh you'll
find the internet is
crazy i agree tyrell the
i have cast more people i've hired more
people
from instagram and from twitter
it's it's uh i would have never thought
that that
that that's that is the way now to uh to
find talent
and they're unafraid they don't there
aren't any rules
and you are you're drawn in like what
the hell
who thinks it is it's good it's good
uh do you feel like marketers and but to
your question emil about the old guard i
mean i don't know
i mean again we spent so much time i did
this play called uh
joan jeff black uh for miss black for
president in chicago which is based on
uh
the life of uh terence allen smith who
was joan jett black
who got on the floor of the 1992 dnc
in drag to run again to you know launch
a campaign from queer nation
um for president of the united states as
far as we know the first black drag
queen to run for president of the united
states
um and and you know i was shocked i
didn't know anything about this story
found it did display about it um found
terence allen smith living in
san francisco and was just again
shocked at what you know the history
that is lost
i mean their whole platform was talking
about you know the aids epidemic at the
time that was
being largely quelled and or
uh quieted by the government um not
unlike what's happening today in terms
of you know
covet cases and who's who's bearing the
brunt of it and whose communities are
sort of really losing anyway it
two things that that happened to me were
one i was once again reminded of a
of a generational loss that we are still
suffering grieving
uh trying to find healing from there are
so many
between you know uh just a little older
than lee
um there's so many men in that
generation who were lost
to the aids epidemic and that so much
talent
um gone and so they're kind of the kind
of you know passing on that lee talks
about
is isn't there one and but two
um there is this moment where you have
to stop
what what i had to not meet anybody
else's breakthrough
moment i'll speak from a place of i i
really had to stop
trying to like think about well how do i
make this nice enough
for the old guard to look at it how do i
i really had to go i want to spend the
rest of my life
aiming all of my energy and love and
nurturing
to people i actually love and care about
we there was this woman this activist
who titled who called herself a
d word uh activist
um that's what she called herself and
she was like you know i spent the first
years of my life fighting for
people to um fighting people who hated
me
to try to love me and and that doesn't
really make sense after a while you get
to an
age i'm i'm about to be 40 and i'm like
i don't want to spend the next 40 years
of my life 20 years of my life
aiming my energy at people who already
hate me or don't
care to love me i want to aim my energy
and people who do care
love me i want to aim my energy at
people i love and care and i want to
wrap my nurturing around them
so you know i think that's a part of
this awakening for me when you know we
talk about woke
my wokeness has more to do with like i
just gotta i want to love on people and
i want to nurture on people and
even if you know even if we've talked
[ __ ] about each other before
behind each other's back that's cool
that's that's over there
right are you okay are you are you
strong are you eating well
are you seeking the help you need are
you you know are you
are are your talents being given the
space and means to do what they can do
um to add to the conversation or are you
being quieted
because sometimes we we see our brothers
and sisters in real pain
and and think because they're acting out
in those ways that that's who they are
and it really is that they're in pain
and we got to go over and be like yo
i see you in pain mad you know may i be
of help as much as i can be
um or do you just need to get out of
your way for a while and that's cool too
but i just i don't know i get tired of
trying to aim my energy
at you know the at white people
who may not if they don't choose to love
us at this point what
what am i going to do about that right
even white gay people we're always
talking about like
the community well you know there's a
lot of white gay people who don't like
black people
you want me to i don't know you i'm not
gonna go and
beat nobody down because they're not
checking for me that's cool
but where are those little black kids
who are growing up learning that it's
okay to hate themselves
how do i get to them that's way
more important to me
yeah and i feel like you have done an
extraordinary job of doing that with
moonlight
with david makes man of you know telling
stories of people that
could have been just forgotten and lost
but actually
had something in their spirit that they
wanted to push forward
and i think that is those are the
important important stories that we need
to tell right now
is like what what are the stories that
have not been told
who are the young people that are
growing up against
crazy odds and how do we amplify their
stories
and change the narrative faces
giving a face to people that aren't seen
and a voice to people that aren't heard
and sometimes you know you got to be
prepared to take the criticism for that
a lot of criticism for monsters ball
an incredible amount of criticism from
monsters ball an incredible amount of
criticism
for precious you know just they just uh
why lee why do you have to show us in
this light
but that is our story you know
who else is going to if i don't
so i'm going to bring sean in because
he's
we're going to add him to ask a few more
questions
um and into the conversation
lee tyrell and emil wow thank you so
much for this thank you so much for your
honesty and for your transparency and
for sharing
your story i've been listening to
everything that you said i had two
questions um one with everything that
you all have said
where where do we go from here where do
we as a community go from here
working more collaboratively together in
this industry
and where can we go as as
as filmmakers and as artists where do we
go from here with everything you guys
mentioned
right here is a great start what we're
where we
are right now in this space the fact
that we're having and we're able to have
this conversation and
a candid conversation as gay men all of
us as black gay men
all of us i don't know that this is
would have been heard of
through the academy so sean thank you
for for putting this together
because where do we go from here we go
with um
people that are thinking like you
forward thinkers like you
that are going to be able to um even
give me the courage
to come out and talk about these things
for the world to see
and these are private thoughts that that
i have been holding on to i'm sure
tyrell has been holding on too too um
but the truth will set you free emil
where do you where do you feel is though
with your
extensive experience in media and
understanding that media is a tool
um where do you believe we can go from
here
well i have to echo lee's thoughts i
mean
having these conversations this is the
this is where we start
to have a conversation with four black
gay men about these
topics and these issues and these real
things that
affect our lives i think that is where
we begin
and i am so um inspired
by both lee and terrell and the work
that you've done because
you have just pushed away the old
guard and and what we would think
black gay men look like or how they're
depicted
and you're showing real humanity and
real stories
and i think that's that's the beginning
and that's where we need to go and we
need to tap in
and let all these young people have the
opportunity to tell their stories
i love that and terrell where do we go
from here tyrell
you know look i i i
i think the sky is the limit in terms of
where we can go
i think we um you know
i hope we go a little inside for a
little bit
meaning i hope we do a whole bunch of
healing
a whole bunch of just introspection um a
whole bunch of
uplifting inside um and i know that may
sound a little
a kumbaya hold hands and jump together
but i i really you know i i again i
thrive on community
and i know for our young people for our
young uh
uh lgbtq folks who are black
to survive they need community they need
elders
they need to know the function of them
but they also need to know that their
space and there's a space in there of
love for them
um and that's the way we get great art
you know that's the way we get
the the most compelling stuff i mean
sometimes yes you get it by
you know the the by pressuring somebody
to to do you know take the
the no the by no any means necessary
route
right and you get good art that way too
but also what what could we get if we
if imagine imagine right now all the
young artists
who are queer and black got and felt
protected enough and safe enough to
imagine without thinking about race
without
thinking about sexuality but just
imagine what
a magic period if their brain isn't
thinking about survival what else could
they be thinking about what
what what dreams may come if they if
they had the ability to stop
thinking about their own untimely death
every third thought
that's what i want for them i want that
for them thank you
and the last question is you all are
very
magical each one of you tell me a time
when you started to realize your
magic and email we can start with you
when did you realize your magic when did
you realize that
all the things that are you are adding
value to you and everyone else around
you
i think for me a lot of the time that i
spent at vibe magazine
um really gave me the opportunity to
understand that i could create space for
voices that weren't going to be heard
for stories that
that were unheard of and also to
to present imagery of black people
um like rock stars like the way that
we really see ourselves but the world
doesn't see us like that
um i think that was the first time and
then
every day with the work with native son
i'm i'm inspired i mean to be able to
see
this come to life and this conversation
and to sit
um with lee and tyrell and yourself i
think
this is beyond us and i think about what
lee said
when it becomes it's a god moment right
it's a community moment
and it is about kind of creating these
spaces
and these conversations
thank you and then terrell what about
you when did you start to realize your
magic
um well it was a little bit of rough
magic or
practical magic because one time
um i just thought you know my mother my
mother had me when she was 16 years old
and um and i ca
i think i was about 12 or 13 but i just
kept trying to imagine her life if she
didn't have a kid at 16 or 17 like what
her life would have been like
she was really smart really beautiful um
and charming you know um
had all those things that a model could
have she was six feet tall she was
slender
um and and i was just like well your
life would have been great if you just
didn't have
have a kid like you you you know and she
slapped me
she uh as we say in in liberty city she
spot
fire my face and um and
she was like if i didn't want you i
wouldn't have had you
and it just made me think and i'm i
really i mean i know it sounds weird but
in that moment i was like oh no she
there was purpose she she had me on
purpose i am here for a purpose
right like she didn't this was an
accidental sort of slip
up she was like no no you were brought
here on purpose
um and i remember from that day on
i just sort of walked around going oh no
i'm here for something
there's something here i'm called to do
um
and it just it shifted my my view of
things radically even in my most
depressing moments i can still kind of
feel that slap
um and remember that no i'm here for
something
i'm here for a reason wow wow
tyrell my mom happened when she was 18.
wow um for me
it was uh it was the uh
i think the first couple of episodes in
uh
on empire you know as a
as an in trying to find your voice you
don't know
you know you're an artist but you don't
really know what your worth is and
you know it was also you know i don't
know
let me just find myself what is i i want
to express myself
and uh but that's a [ __ ] thing to do
that's not really that's not work is
that work
is that real work you know and so uh you
know my brother
was in jail um
uh during um empire
and uh he's four years three years
younger than me
and he
he was embarrassed about who it was that
i was
and so when you live with that
embarrassment from your
from your brother and your father you
really think that you are
it affects you deeply it affects you it
affects you you know uh
you are alone and uh
three episodes we didn't talk uh we
still don't really talk but
um three episodes in
and the numbers were just going through
the roof and people couldn't understand
why people were watching this
i got in a letter from him uh
from jail and
he apologizing and um
i broke down i think it was the biggest
uh
award that i've ever gotten was from him
and he said that when empire was on
the entire um prison
shut down you could hear a pin drop
3 000 men were glued to that television
and uh i wept when i got that letter
um i wept i didn't return that i would i
wanted to write him back but i didn't
know how to write him back
uh because i was it so much had
gone we had gone through so much by then
we were in our 50s
and uh but i knew that
i had a voice and that everything that
had put me
through everything that i've been
through
that i was communicating to 3 000
men up in that prison and they were
focused
on my word and that's a powerful thing i
said oh my god
i got a little magic in me you know
i think it's more than a little magic
and the three of you on this
on this call and i just wanted to say on
behalf of
the academy and the members and everyone
who's going to be tuning in and
participating thank you so much for
lending your
light your transparency for sharing your
stories
emil wobukin thank you so much for
moderating this conversation
lee daniels as always thank you so much
for showing up and being your true self
tarot ivan mccraney thank you all so
much for participating in academy
dialogues
thank you thank you